all change happens a lot slower than we
think and that's why when people see
people they admire or they read books
about
transformation I think they can often be
misleading and make people think that
change is like a right turn when like
the right turn is usually happening in a
series of very very very very tiny steps
you and I are close enough friends that
I think you've seen smaller steps of
mine I think big changes happen very
very slowly and accepting that is super
important because when I see people whip
their life around when they think they
want a big change it usually either
spirals them into depression or it's not
an effective way to actually make the
change or it leaves them with like a
tangible change but not the time to like
emotionally change with it to evolve as
a person